now the Prime Minister Rishi sinach has
expressed concern over growing tensions
in the West Bank that's as he met the
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu in Downing Street this morning
[Applause]
or shouts from protesters could be heard
as the two leaders shook hands there on
the doorstep of number 10 the visit
comes with Mr Netanyahu facing a
national crisis back at home that's over
his plans to overhaul Israel's Judiciary
System
well joining me now is our political
correspondent Amanda acasser hello again
to you Amanda some dramatic scenes there
as as the two men shook hands outside
number 10.
um the Prime Minister expressing his
concern at Rising tension in the West
Bank
yes so we're told in their 45 by later
45 minutes bilateral meeting the two
leaders discussed International concern
about Rising tensions in the West Bank
and encouraged any move towards
de-escalation and in particular anything
that would encourage movements towards
progress towards a two State solution
also quite interestingly given the
protests that we can hear outside
Downing Street at the moment and indeed
protests which have been going on across
Israel around concerns about the
right-wing government in Israel's moves
to water down the power of the courts
and in particular concerns about changes
in the law which will make it much
harder for for judges to remove a leader
deemed unfit for office bearing in mind
Mr Netanyahu himself is on trial for
corruption charges which he denies he of
course argues that these changes are
needed to ensure that unelected judges
don't overturn decisions reached by
democratically elected politicians but
Mr sunac did bring this issue up it's
quite clearfully worded but we're told
that the Prime Minister stressed the
importance of upholding the democratic
values that underpin our relationship
including in the proposed judicial
reforms in Israel now otherwise we're
told the two leaders discussed a joint
security concerns around the invasion of
Ukraine also the situation with Iran
also discussed joint 20 million pounds
going towards their Science and
Technology projects as well as saying
that their two teams will be working at
PACE together to try and reach a modern
Free Trade Agreement